okay good morning everyone hope you're
all doing well my name is nick barbarous
I'm a professor of finance at the School
of Management here at Yale and I'd like
to welcome you all back to campus hope
you're having a good time so far so as
you know the university is a leading
force in many areas of research and so
it is also for the School of Management
but it's a leading school in many areas
of research and I wanted to talk to you
today about just one area of research
within management that Yael som is
particularly well known for which is
behavioral finance it's a large inactive
area of financial economics that Yale is
on by many people thought to have some
of the leading research group in the
country and I wanted to apply this in
particular to talking about the recent
financial crisis the financial crisis
was still going through and you'll see
in a second what that means is we're
really going to be talking about the
psychology of the financial crisis so
I'm gonna talk not for very long
I promise and then leave lots of times
for any questions or discussion points
you may have I would appreciate it if
you might keep your questions until the
end because we're actually being filmed
today so might be easier to keep the
questions until the end I suspect that
some of you have a lot of background in
finance financial markets and so on but
I am gonna try and keep this talk quite
simple so that it's intelligible even to
people that don't have any background in
finance or in financial markets but I
hope that nonetheless there'll be
something here of interest for everyone
and the last thing I'd ask is if you
could sort of put your cell phones on
vibrate or on silent at least for the
next hour again because of the filming
so just a little bit of background first
about behavioral finance what's all this
about um so I think a lot of you know
that when economists try to explain how
financial markets work they always
assume that everyone out there is
rational and what does that mean
rationality means a couple of things
first of all it means that when you get
new information you update your beliefs
correctly and secondly it means that
given your beliefs you make sensible
decisions and it would be wonderful if
that explained the world because it's a
very
simple and parsimonious way of looking
at things but it's become pretty clear
the lots of things like the tech stock
bubble in the late 1990s the recent
housing bubble just don't fit that
framework very well well luckily there's
an alternative it's been around for
decades and it's called behavioral
finance and it argues that lots of
financial phenomena out there might be
the result of less than fully rational
decision-making on the part of some
people and it advocates reading the
psychology literature closely to try and
understand the ways in which people are
less than fully rational particularly
the work of Daniel Kahneman who won the
Nobel Prize for this work a few years
ago and for Amos Tversky his colleague
who would have won the Nobel Prize also
unfortunately passed away a few years
ago and it's been applied to
understanding the pricing of financial
assets how ordinary people like us
invest and trade over time and aspects
of corporate finance as well so I hope
you see that there's really two schools
of thought in academia but also in the
practitioner world about how financial
markets work there's kind of the
rational agents camp so these people
believe that everything is the result of
rational decision making and then
there's the behavioral finance camp
which argues that some stuff out there
might be the result of less than fully
rational decision-making and some of the
best-known people leading the discussion
on each side are these so on the
rational agent side my former colleague
I used to teach at the University of
Chicago my former colleague Jean farmer
and on the behavioral finance side my
current colleague here at Yale Bob
Shiller I suspect many of you have heard
of through his books irrational
exuberance and more recently animal
spirits and his presence here at Yale is
a significant reason why Yale is
considered a leading research group in
this area but it's not just him there's
actually a large group of us that work
on this kind of research and I have to
say that both of these people are very
likely to win Nobel prizes at some point
but you know obviously not in the same
year because they say largely
contradictory things so what I wanted to
do today was just sort of apply
behavioral finance a little bit to the
financial crisis we've been going
through we're still going through so
what this is going to be is the role of
less than fully rational thinking in the
crisis in other words psychological
factors that might have created and
enhanced the crisis that's really what
the discussions going to be so let's do
just out of a one minute overview of
this crisis how can we describe it in
simple terms um so you might think that
there are some loan originators sort of
local lenders who make loans to local
borrowers for example even subprime
borrowers and then those loans are sold
to investment banks which package them
into securities like mortgage-backed
securities CDOs and so on and those are
rated by certain ratings agencies and
then sold to end investors and I guess
sort of that 4/32 summary of the
financial crisis is just that these
subprime borrowers defaulted so the
value of these securities associated
with these loans held by the investment
banks on their asset side of the balance
sheet went down a lot in value the banks
became very nervous they stopped lending
and the economy slowed and if you read
the financial press there's really two
narratives that they gave about what
happened here and you can think a little
bit about which narrative you believe
the first narrative is what I might call
the bad incentives view so here that the
story is banks knew all along that these
loans had a significant chance of
default and there could be trouble but
they just didn't care because their
incentives led them to keep originating
and packaging these loans their
incentives were based on the quantity of
the deals they were doing not on the
quality of the deals not on not on the
quality so I suspect that there is some
truth to this a lot of people believe
there is some truth to this that the
incentives were bad but I don't think
it's a complete explanation because
senior figures that many of these banks
did suffer large financial losses during
the crisis so would they really have
pursued the strategy that they did if
they were aware of the risks wouldn't
they have preferred to instead scale
back their activities a bit and some
banks like Goldman Sachs for example did
exactly that
so I don't think it's a complete
explanation
then there's a second view a second
narrative well I'll call the bad models
view the bad models narrative this says
there was nothing wrong with banks
incentives they simply failed to
forecast the severity the likelihood of
a collapse the models they were using to
forecast the future just fail to take
into account the possibility for example
of a national downturn in housing prices
failed to take into account extreme
events which we often call fat tales and
I think this is definitely true to some
extent the models these banks were using
were just not adequate but it doesn't
strike me as a complete explanation or
something's missing here how could so
many smart well-trained people working
at these banks be comfortable with such
deficient models it doesn't quite add up
it doesn't quite make sense so I don't
think either of these stories fully
captures what's going on so I want to
suggest to you something else today
again which has its roots in behavioral
finance so the story I want to suggest
today is something a little bit
different I want to suggest that on some
level banks were aware that there were
problems with the business model they
were pursuing but as a result of a
number of psychological factors they
essentially deluded themselves into
thinking that everything was okay and
they just kept going so I'm going to
push that narrative a little bit today
and I'm also in the second part of the
talk gonna talk a little bit about some
psychological factors that may be
relevant to a couple of the other
intriguing aspects of this crisis the
fact that trading has completely dried
up in certain markets which is very
puzzling the belief that a lot of people
had their house prices would just keep
on rising where did that belief come
from and the willingness of many
households to take out excessively large
loans what might have propelled that so
really what I'm going to do is just pick
out a number of important ideas from
cognitive and social psychology and
argue that they may have played a role
and really it's too early for me to
really present rigorous research I'm
really just suggesting some ideas that
we might pursue in the next few months
and then at the end you can tell me
which ones you find more or less
plausible all right so first idea
perhaps the most famous idea in social
psychology cognitive dissonance so as
many of you will remember cognitive
dissonance is the discomfort we feel
when we take an action that conflict
with our typically positive self-image
and to remove this sense of discomfort
what we often do is we manipulate our
beliefs so a simple example is smoking
suppose you're a smoker would you say to
yourself is look you know I'm a sensible
person but here I am smoking which is
bad for my long-run health so that
induces dissonance why am i a sensible
person doing something that's bad for my
long-run health so that induces a sense
of discomfort dissonance so what do you
do well you could just quit smoking but
that's difficult so instead you
manipulate your beliefs you tell
yourself that smoking really isn't that
risky or you think of that 90 year old
person down the road who's been smoking
all of his life and is perfectly fine
you tell yourself stories like that so
you can very simply apply this to recent
activity at the bank so you can just say
look the people working at the banks
typically had a very positive self-image
they were typically very smart great
education great interpersonal skills
often Yale graduates they really felt
they were wonderful what wonderful
people so any sign that what they were
doing was not sensible would quickly
induce dissonance right why how I can I
a wonderfully sensible and talented
person be engaged in a business model
that doesn't make any sense
so that induces dissonance what do you
do you manipulate your beliefs oh you
tell yourself that you know what this
business model isn't so messed up or you
ignore warning signs and keep on
pursuing the path you are pursuing sort
of ignoring indications that what you're
doing doesn't make any sense because you
all want to avoid dissonance another
very famous idea from social psychology
conformity we have a very strong
tendency to conform to what the group we
belong to is doing even if we don't
think it makes sense and we think that
this stems from a very basic human need
to be liked and accepted by others and
the classic demonstration of this that
many of you may remember are the
line experiments from the 1950 which I
can describe quite simply what you have
is an experiment or over here on the
right and a group of subjects and what
the experimenter does is ask each of the
sub subjects in turn to state publicly
the answer to the following question
which of these three lines on the right
here is closest in length to this
original line simple question so what
happens is all the subjects except one
are accomplices of the experimenter and
in one point and in one particular trial
they all deliberately give the wrong
answer and then the interesting question
is what does the final person who's not
an accomplice what does that person say
does he give the correct answer or
because of a desire to conform does he
publicly give the erroneous answer so in
this example you can see clearly the
right answer is line C but in one trial
six out of these seven subjects
deliberately said a and then the
question was what would the seventh
person say and the remarkable finding is
that more than 50% of the time the
seventh subject will say a quite even
though it's clearly the wrong answer
we'll just say a because he or she
really wants to conform and it's you
probably can't see it very well but it's
actually very funny to to see a close-up
here these are the accomplices and this
is the poor subject who's not not in on
the game and the expression on his face
is just priceless
I mean he's deeply confused he's staring
staring at these lines on the board and
not knowing what's going on but because
of the need to conform says so you can
see the application of this as well to
the recent crisis you might be working
in a bank and you see signs of trouble
but because of the need the desire to
conform you just don't say anything you
just don't cause a fuss you say to
yourself look no one else working here
is saying anything so I'm not gonna say
anything either because I want to
conform and the studies have shown that
this is particularly strong when the
group you belong to exhibits what's
called
Stremme strength or immediacy a strength
is the importance of the group to you
and immediacy is the proximity of the
group and I think both of these are
quite acute if you're working in one of
these banks you really enjoy working
there so the group is important to you
and of course the people in the group
are right around you on the trading
floor for example so we think the
conformity is the desire for it is quite
strong in this situation now an
extension of the conformity idea is
another idea I suspect as some of you
are familiar with which is groupthink
and this is an idea that was developed
here at Yale in the 1970s by or earlier
so in the 1950s by Irving Janis and it's
a kind of thinking in which group
cohesiveness is more important than
carefully considering the fact and it's
thought to be particularly strong when
and here are sort of some of the
symptoms when the group is valued and
attractive to belong to when the group
is isolated from other opinions when
there's a strong leader who makes his
view known when the situation stressful
and there's no process for considering
other viewpoints those are some of the
the factors that lead to groupthink and
some of the symptoms of it are that
people decide not to voice contrary
opinion so as not to rock the boat
there's pressure on dissenters to
conform and opposing opinions are
stereotyped in a simplistic way and many
of you may know that the original
groupthink studies were aimed at
understanding the Bay of Pigs disaster
why was the group of people charged with
making the decision about that
expedition why did they get it so wrong
and Janus suspected groupthink but it's
been applied in many other situations
the invasion of career in 1950
escalation of the Vietnam War in the
1960s and more recently as you all know
to the CIA assessment of the state of
Iraqi weaponry well you can see again
the application to the current crisis
what strikes me is that many of the
contributing factors to groupthink are
indeed met if you look at some of these
the group is valued and attractive to
belong to if you're on the board of
directors say of one of these large
banks that's a really nice
group to belong to and you really want
to keep belonging to that group that can
contribute to groupthink the group is
isolated from other opinions if you look
at the backgrounds of the people who are
on these boards of directors they're not
as diverse as you would like them to be
there's not enough divergence enough
sort of differing viewpoints contributed
there's a strong leader who makes his
views known that was certainly true in
some cases if you think of Stan O'Neal
at Merrill Lynch he was very clear that
he wanted the bank to expand into risky
mortgage related areas and therefore the
group just follows suit just follows his
thinking so it strikes us that there are
not many of the preconditions for
groupthink are indeed met okay another
very famous idea from social psychology
again an idea developed here at Yale
which I think many of you may know is
the obedience idea the famous Milgram
experiments from the 1960s and the basic
conclusion there was people are
remarkably willing to follow
instructions from an authority figure
even when the task seems completely
inappropriate so I suspect that many of
you had to learn about these studies as
a famous Yale research contribution
during your undergraduate years but let
me briefly repeat what what happened as
you know we can't really do experiments
of this kind anymore so there's an
experimenter and there's two subjects a
teacher and a student and what happens
is the teacher is supposed to teach a
few things to the student and then test
the student on these things and if the
student gets something wrong the teacher
is supposed to give the student what he
believes to be an electric shock this is
why we can't do these experiments
anymore obviously so the important thing
to understand here is that the electric
shocks are not real the teacher believes
them to be real but the student who is
an accomplice of the experimenter is
does not actually feel anything but
pretends that they are real so there's a
lot of acting and shrieking and shouting
going on to make it appear
the shocks are real so the way this
proceeds is you know the teacher teaches
a few things the student and then test
the student asks him a question and the
student will deliberately get something
wrong and then the experimenter says
okay please deliver the first shock and
the question is whether the teacher does
so if he does so then we continue and
the student gets another question wrong
and the experimenter says okay please
now deliver a stronger electric shock
and the question is whether the teacher
does so and then we keep going
in many cases obviously the teacher
feels uncomfortable and sort of unsure
what to do and looks to the experimenter
and the experimenter says things like it
is important that you continue or please
continue as we discussed earlier and it
turns out that just simple nudges like
that are enough to lead 60% of the
teachers to deliver what they believe to
be even the strongest electric shock of
450 volts so those are the slightly
disturbing conclusions from this very
well-known studies by Milgram here at
Yale in the 1960s so what's going on
there's a huge amount of research about
what's going on in these experiments
there's sort of a feeling that the two
most important things are just
psychologically we're reluctant to
disappoint an authority figure
even if we're never going to see them
again and secondly in confusing
situations we often look to authority
figures for guidance on what to do now
you may find it a little bit of a
stretch but I actually think these ideas
are relevant in recent goings-on
in the banks I think a lot of people
working in banks may have felt that what
they were doing was not appropriate we
have all these stories from Washington
Mutual wasn't it of giving sort of three
hundred thousand dollar loans to
mariachi singers or whatever else people
were being asked to do and you know
there's a sense that that's not an
appropriate thing to do but people may
have felt a psychological need to do
what their bosses wanted and their
bosses wanted them to make these loans
it is important as Milgram said that you
continue as we discussed so people may
have felt this cycle
need to please the authority figure and
in confusing situations such as this one
you look to the authority figure your
boss for guidance as to what to do and
if your bosses do it you just do it so
it's not just a matter of getting
concern about getting fired I'm talking
that in addition to that these
psychological considerations that
Milgram is identifying the last thing
I'd mention on this particular section
of the talk is diffusion of
responsibility another basic finding in
psychology is that when there are many
different parties that contribute to
some flawed process it's very easy for
any one of them to blame the others and
to absolve themselves of any
responsibility and therefore to not take
any corrective action and one of the
things that's very striking if you
remember the flowchart I showed you at
the start of the talk was how many
different parties are involved in this
process you know there's the borrower
there's the mortgage broker the mortgage
originator the investment bank the
ratings agency the end investor and so
on and because there are so many parties
involved is very easy for any one of
them to say look I'm not doing anything
wrong if there is something wrong here
at someone else that's contributing and
then you just keep on doing what you do
so what we just did is we talked a
little bit about some of the problems
with decision making within the banks
that was sort of the first part of the
talk the things I wanted to do just in
the last part of the talk is pick out
some of the other puzzling things that
have happened during this financial
crisis and isolate some other
psychological factors that we think
might be relevant in particular I wanted
to talk about the lack of trading in
many debt markets one really puzzling
thing in the past few months is that
there are certain markets where trading
has almost completely dried up and
that's sort of a very very rare
occurrence in markets and I want to
mention two ideas the idea of trust and
ambiguity aversion related to that
another big contributor to the housing
bubble was this belief that many people
had that house prices would just keep on
rising for a long time where on earth
did we get that idea I want to mention
two ideas of representativeness and
overconfidence that might have
contributed to that
and finally the willingness of
individuals to really take out excessive
loans larger loans
than was really financially sane and
again I want to mention two ideas
representativeness and optimism related
to that all right so the first thing the
lack of trading in many markets where
might that come from so we mentioned the
idea of trust we talked a lot about a
credit crisis and a lot of people have
observed the the root of the word credit
credit or trust or to believe so one
idea that's that's come up a lot of
people have suggested is that the lack
of trading in some markets may be the
result of a deterioration in the level
of trust among market participants so
Trust is an idea that you think we might
be studying more in finance but we
actually haven't studied it as much as
we should but there are some recent
studies which are quite intriguing so
there was one done recently on 2,000
households in the Netherlands 2,000
Dutch households and a remarkable
finding from this population is that
less trusting households invested less
in the stock market participated less in
the stock market less trusting
households in a general sense invested
less in the stock market and Trust is
measured through survey questions like
this one generally speaking would you
say that most people can be trusted or
that you have to be careful in dealing
with people that very general question
it turns out predicts the level of
investment in the stock market your
participation in the stock market is
very striking to see trusts come in like
that not only does it predict levels of
participation within the country but it
also helps explain something else very
puzzling which is why there are very
different participation levels across
countries so for instance in Europe one
puzzling thing is why do people in some
countries invest quite heavily in the
stock market and people in other
countries hardly at all and this has
been a long-standing puzzle but recent
studies suggest that Trust plays an
issue so here's a picture showing you
the cross-sectional relationship you've
got the level of trust in various
countries along the horizontal and how
much the wealthy citizens participate in
a stock market on the vertical and you
can see a clear
positive relationship in countries where
there's more trust again measured
through that survey question on the
previous page there's more participation
in the stock market so Sweden which is
the most trusting country in Europe
invest the most in the stock market
Greece the least trusting country in
Europe invests the least so one idea
that people have mentioned in the past
year is that you know over the course of
the past few months there may have just
been an evaporation of the notion of
trust and that may be really important
for the willingness to participate in
asset markets perhaps helping us to
understand why there's been so little
trading in some markets another idea we
think is important here is something
that has a slightly fancy terminology
ambiguity aversion it's actually quite a
simple idea
a famous idea goes back to Daniel
Ellsberg in the 1960s is this basic fact
people strongly dislike situations where
they don't feel able to assign
probabilities to outcomes ambiguity
aversion a very simple demonstration of
this I can give you just in one slide
based on a couple of urns I hope you'll
remember your urns from your statistics
classes in undergraduate so earn see is
a certain earn that's what the C stands
for and it has 100 balls in it and 50 of
them are red and 50 of them are black
then there's earn you the uncertain earn
as well the U stands for also contains a
hundred balls and some are red and some
are black they're all either red or
black you just don't know the proportion
of each so then we ask people to choose
between the following two bets r1 and r2
here's the difference with r1 I'm just
gonna draw a ball from the certain urn
and you'll get $20 if it's red
r2 I'm gonna draw a ball from the
uncertain urn and you'll get $20 if it's
red and you can think a little bit about
which of those two bets you would prefer
and then you ask another question kind
of related which is choose between these
two bets b1 and b2 so b1 this time we're
going to draw
all from the certain own this time
you'll get $20 of it's black and then b2
is let's draw a ball from the uncertain
urn and you'll get $20 of its black so
what's interesting is people tend to
choose r1 over r2 and b1 / b2 but that's
considered a paradox and you can
probably see why because it's not
consistent with any beliefs you might
have about the composition of the
uncertain urn your willingness to take
r1 over r2 means that you think that
fewer than 50% of the balls in the
uncertain own are red but will your
willingness to choose b1 / b2 means that
you believe that more than 50% of the
balls in the uncertain own are red so
there's a conflict there and this is the
Ellsberg paradox and often called
ambiguity aversion in other words the
explanation or what this phenomenon is
label it's labeled ambiguity aversion we
don't like ambiguity we don't like
situations where as in the uncertain urn
we're not able to assign probabilities
to outcome so you can see the
application quite easily here given the
news we've had in the last few months
over the past year traders have become
extremely nervous in the sense that they
just don't feel able to assign
probabilities to different outcomes it's
very hard to predict what's going to
happen it's very hard to know what level
of defaults there are going to be and
since people are scared of that kind of
ambiguity they may just withdraw from
the asset market perhaps again
explaining the low level of trading in
some markets
all right second thing I wanted to pull
out was turning to a slightly different
different fact which is you know this
belief that a lot of people had that
house prices would just keep on rising
indefinitely which we think was a major
contributing factor to the bubble and to
the excessive lending because people
were saying it's okay to lend this
person some money even if they don't
have a good credit history because in
two years the house will be worth more
they can just refinance and so on it
will all be fine
so everything was predicated on some
notion that house prices would just keep
on rising where on earth did that come
from so some some psychology that it may
be linked to is an idea of called
representativeness it's a famous idea of
Daniel Kahneman and Amos Tversky you can
boil it down sort of a complex idea but
I can boil it down very simply to say
people have a tendency to see patterns
in data that's actually completely
random and the pattern that people
particularly love to see is a trend
people see trends in data that's
actually completely random and a famous
example of this is the so called hot
hand phenomenon in basketball all of you
may be familiar with so you have some
basketball game you have you have two
players who are roughly the same average
ability but in this particular game one
of them has made the last three shots
one of them has missed the last three
shots and you ask people okay which of
the two players would you give the ball
to at this moment overwhelmingly people
say the person who has made the last few
shots because they feel that they've
seen some kind of trend some kind of hot
streak that's going to be continued so
in the 1980s some psychologists you know
bit puzzled about this they decided to
get the data and take a look they got a
long time series of data from a major
basketball franchise and what they found
is there's no predictability at all in
the data it turns out that someone who's
made the last three shots has a point
four six chance of making the next one
someone who's missed the last three
shots has a point five six chance of
making the next one you're actually more
likely to make it if you missed the last
three shots so people are seeing a trend
in the data where there isn't one
so that makes it a little bit easier to
understand what happened here
prices had been rising for a long time
for several years until recently and if
people do have a tendency to extrapolate
trends too far into the future then
maybe that's where this belief came from
the house prices would just keep on
rising it was amplified by this
representativeness tendency I think
another thing that was going on all
contributing was so-called
overconfidence one of the most famous
ideas in cognitive psychology a very
basic idea which is that people strongly
overestimate the precision of their
forecasts so very simple way this is
demonstrated is you ask people to
forecast something whatever it could
just be a company's earnings next
quarter or next year but not just give
you a point estimate but also give you a
confidence interval for example let's
see a 95% confidence interval so that
you're 95% sure that the actual number
will fall in that interval and then
later on you can go and check how often
does the actual number fall in that
interval and over some studies from many
different domains what you find is that
the actual number falls in the interval
only about 60% of the time so people are
giving a confidence interval that's way
too narrow suggesting that they're too
confident about the precision of their
forecasts so this too could have
contributed to the poor modeling or the
poor predictions we had about the future
course of house prices because of
overconfidence we thought we could
predict the future course of Health's
prices better than we really could we
didn't take into account the possibility
that they could be a national downturn
in housing prices perhaps again because
of overconfidence in our estimate and
the last thing I wanted to mention was
this this thing that happened that lots
of households took out loans that were
just too large that we're not
financially sensible why did that happen
well I think the representativeness this
extrapolation of past trends played a
role in that if you think that house
prices are just going to keep on going
up then you probably will
take out a loan that's larger than you
should because you think well in two
years the house will be worth more I can
just refinance and so on but I think
another aspect that's relevant is
another famous phenomenon will you
simply labeled optimism and it refers to
the fact that people tend to have
excessively rosy views of their future
prospects and this kind of thing is very
seat symbol to establish you just ask
people how likely they think certain
setbacks are in their own case and in
the case of say their college roommate
or their neighbors things like that and
people overwhelmingly think that
setbacks are much more likely to happen
to their roommate or their neighbor much
more likely to happen to those people
than to me setbacks like whether it's
getting a divorce having a drinking
problem having a car accident cancer all
these kinds of things it's going to
happen to other people it's not going to
happen to me so you can see the
application here once again you know you
might worry a little bit about the
chance of default if you take out an
excessively large loan but then because
of optimism you might say oh defaulting
that's just something that happens to
other people to my roommate to my
neighbor it's not something that will
happen to me and then as a result you
take on two large alone all right
I think I've talked enough I think I'd
like to hear a little bit from from you
as well just to remind you of what we
talked about I sort of mentioned these
two narratives that people have put
forward in the financial press for what
happened over the past year the bad
incentives narrative that banks kind of
knew what was going on but their
incentives just led them to continue
doing what they were doing the bad model
view which is that the incentives were
fine banks simply didn't have very good
forecasts of what was going to happen in
the future and one thing I'm curious
about is which if any of those two views
you find more compelling but what I
wanted to do today was to suggest this
alternative view today more based on
psychology and behavioral finance which
is that banks at some level may have
been aware that there were problems with
their business model but as a result of
a number of social psychological factors
they deluded themselves effectively into
thinking that everything was okay and
ignoring warning signs and we mentioned
ideas like cognitive dissonance
conformity groupthink and obedience and
at the end there I wanting to pick out
three other puzzling things and link
those to certain pieces of psychology as
well the lack of trading in some debt
markets and I linked that to trust an
ambiguity aversion this belief we all
had that house prices would keep on
rising and I linked out to
representativeness and overconfidence
and a willingness of a lot of people to
take out loans that were too large and I
linked that again to representativeness
and optimism so let me stop there and
just see if there are any questions but
not just questions because I suspect
that in this group there's gonna be a
lot of informed viewpoints and I'm
actually very interested in hearing what
do you think about recent events thank
you very much I've taught I've taught
this stuff for a long time I love all
this stuff I think it's financially
rewarding to understand this but I had a
couple little minor points since I teach
finance students at a university much
lower in the food chain and Yale but
these the people go out and do all these
kinds of things right without a Yale
education and I teach some finance and
they can't do the most basic discounting
they can't do the most basic
calculations and finance I think one of
the things you left out is that you have
to allow for ignorant and stupidity when
I'm serious about that
I love teaching I love teaching these
students but the point is a lot of them
just don't get it and you if you've been
to a closing I mean you know what that
stack of papers looks like and you're
signing forms that just say you
understand you signed a previous form
and and you write checks you can't
possibly even if you're good you might
miss some stuff but if you can't do any
of the basic calculations or understand
what an APR really isn't I think you
have to allow for that as part of the
problem okay and and so then another
simple solution you talked about one
thing that bothered me was the lack of
trading and you didn't mention Akerlof
you know Akerlof did spend some time at
Yale didn't he I think in the past and
his lemons model I thought is a really
good explanation of that where there's
asymmetric information the reason you
don't trade is you think the person on
the other side of the trade has more
information than you do
and he showed you know that's why he won
the Nobel Prize that that's one of the
reasons right and so I think that would
be that would be a nice that would be a
nice addition and I think you could also
add the authority figures when you're at
the closing you have authority figures
telling you everything's all right and
I'm speaking from personal experience I
bought a house in San Diego in 2005 and
so
so I had to is her fault
okay that's no she wasn't the authority
figure she's the reason I bought the
house but in that room right and I was
complaining that this is a bubble and
you know I bought some insurance on one
of those little tiny markets I couldn't
insure enough against it but everybody
in the room said don't worry in a year
the price of your house will be 20%
higher and so and I knew that was a
bunch of baloney but anybody normally
would say okay these people are in the
business they all know about this and so
it's easy so that would be an extra tie
in that authority figures they're
telling these people that this is all
fine and so you should sign alone don't
worry about it and so I think that would
be that would be another addition thing
things thank you thank you very much I
knew when I saw you you'd be a good
person to pick on for the first question
I actually do I do agree with would
would you agree with what you say the
only thing I would say is it may be too
simple and explanation that the first
element of sort of ignorance and so on
for some of what happened I think we
just can't deny that some of the people
at these banks that we're doing a lot of
this kind of work were well-trained were
smart intelligent people from good
universities so it's a little bit tricky
to sort of say that what they were doing
was the result of ignorance in all cases
I do agree that the situation is very
complex sort of like a closing as you
said it is very complex the question is
what do people do in complex situations
I think that's where the psychology is
helpful it sort of gives us a framework
of saying in complex situations what
what my people do um I love your point
about Olaf and his lemons so just a
little bit of background there this idea
that this this puzzle that there is that
there's no trading in some debt markets
there's there's two competing
explanations one is ambiguity aversion
as I told you that we just don't know
what the probability distribution of the
outcomes is that scares us as human
being so we all back off another more
sort of classic explanation is the sort
of lemons idea which is asymmetric
information one of the parties knows
less than another and therefore you
don't want to trade because you're
worried that you
gonna trade and be disadvantaged in the
trade because the other person is more
informed and actually there's been quite
a lot of active debate about which of
those two views is right but I have had
a sense that people are inclining more
to the ambiguity aversion view because
they really think that everyone in the
market is confused and there's very
little there's not one party that really
has a very good understanding of how
these of the future of the probability
distribution of future cash flows
everyone is confused and that's why
we're inclining a little bit more to the
ambiguity aversion idea but I'm glad you
brought it up thank ya so the question
is about the fact that they were sort of
government mandating of a lot of the
expansion of lending particularly to do
more disadvantaged members of society
and I agreed there was definitely such a
push and I think what may have happened
is you you I think you put it well I
think that a lot of banks may have used
that as a rationalization what we're
doing is not a bad thing this is what
the government wanted all along we're
giving loans to people who really need
them this is a good thing that we're
doing was really if they thought more
carefully I think they'd figured out
that they had gone too far of course
there should be some expansion of
lending make sure these lending
opportunities are available to everyone
but there is such a thing as going too
far I think we went way over the line
I've been selling real estate for 45
years I own a little real estate company
overlooking Harvard Square people make a
complex situation out of what is really
a very simple choice you want to live
somewhere you've chosen your community
you have not one option but two you can
rent or you can buy and for years I've
been urging people just compare the
costs of the two you know what the rent
is you find two houses that you like
about equally compare the monthly total
of the mortgage cost 30-year fixed-rate
mortgage if you want you can deduct the
tax benefits that your accountant tells
you and compare the mortgage and taxes
versus the rent if they're about the
same you can buy with confidence because
even if the market drops you can rent it
out and cover your costs you're hedged
by the way I wrote that and
Marin's published it in july 2005 that
sounds like sage advice and one thing
that my colleague Bob Shiller is very
keen on is just more more financial
education more more accessible financial
education to more people so that we can
make more informed decisions about
things like like buying houses yes but I
did not hear you refer it all to the
political leadership which was largely
touting a millennialist approach to a
new economy such as we had never seen
that the old rules no longer applied
that a total what seemed to me is an
interest interested president history
lack of historical perspective that was
widely sold to the to the population and
certainly seemed to me to be feeding
into this sense of optimism the leaders
were not advocating caution and the sage
advice of the realtor that we just heard
from the best and the brightest
apparently weren't as smart as all of
them thought they were either and there
was as a result of 9/11 also a kind of
demonization of dissent on many fronts
where people were charged with not
supporting the economy giving aid and
comfort to the enemy and many factors
that fed into the lack of desire to rock
the boat by strongly representing other
opinions so and the last point is a
sense of individualism that everybody by
themselves is going to save themselves
and to hell with the polity and social
compassion a total lack of social
concern greed is good and the individual
engine of greed is going to make this
market serve everyone and I think we've
put paid to that now interested in your
thoughts yes so you're sort of giving
you sort of giving voice to to a certain
to a certain narrative and I suspect
there's a lot of truth in what you say
but let me let me let me let me mention
that there is a more benign view of all
this that before we sort of completely
rush to judgment which is the bad model
narrative that I mentioned that I think
has a lot of truth to it which is it's
not that these banks are full of bad
people or evil people or anything like
that the models they were using to
forecast the future were just not very
good they didn't take into account the
fact that there could be a national
downturn in housing prices and now it's
very easy to say oh those models should
have been better how foolish they were
to not have better models but at the
time it was not so obvious to really
understand that there could be a large
decline in real estate prices you had to
anticipate a number of amplification
mechanisms that we understand now but
may have been a little bit tricky to to
forecast at the time for instance the
amplification mechanism whereby you know
when a house forecloses it's often
vacant that drags down the prices of
other houses in the neighborhood which
then impels them to foreclose and
there's a spiral that occurs there now
we understand that but it may not have
been that easy to forecast at the time
another piece of evidence I'll give you
for the bad models view is if it was so
obvious that everything was so messed up
and that we were heading towards
disaster you would have seen a large
number of hedge funds make a lot of
money by just betting on the fact that a
lot of these securities would plunge in
value very few hedge funds made a lot of
money we hear about john paulson making
a lot of money he's the only one it was
even these very smart hedge fund
managers were not able to foresee this
disaster so there is a more benign
narrative that I do want to emphasize
which is that it was just hard to
foresee a lot of this exposed it's easy
to criticize and I do think there's some
criticism that should go around but I
want I do want to put the B'nai
narrative on the table as well
practically practically everyone in this
room can as soon as the meeting is over
go on the phone and go either long or
short one or another of these securities
and I suspect none of us will do so
either long or short and I think what we
have is in the current situation is a
tremendous lack of conviction among
thoughtful people as to what the future
holds even such fundamental questions as
to whether inflation or deflation is
more likely are not clear
you can argue them but I don't know too
many people who are consonant of their
and if in the absence of confidence
people are reluctant to take positions
not because the guy on the other side of
the trade is smarter than you are
because whichever half of us would want
to go long isn't actually any better
informed in whichever half of us would
want to go short so none of us do
anything yeah you're speaking a little
bit to the so the question that came up
earlier which is is this is this passive
behavior we're all exhibiting is it
really an asymmetric information issue
that we just scared the person on the
other side knows a lot or that none of
us really knows anything we're just very
hard to predict the future and therefore
we just don't do anything and you seem
to be embracing a little bit the latter
view and I completely agree with that
I definitely believe and and see the
psychological forces that are at play in
the in the current economic recession
I'm curious more now we're talking a lot
about regulation to prevent this from
happening again and I'm curious if it's
something that is so psychological maybe
not to completely explain the crisis but
if it's such sort of innate behavior how
do we regulate it and and how do we do
something to prevent it from happening
again yeah so we're reading a lot about
regulation in the financial press more
regulation of derivatives and so on and
I think some regulation on those
dimensions is certainly a good idea but
let me speak a little bit more to your
question which is what kind of eye what
kind of action should we take if you
embrace the psychology based approach
here I think the main thing I would say
is that perhaps organization should be
structured in ways that lead to better
decision-making in other words be aware
of these various things be aware of
conformity or be aware of groupthink and
try to structure the decision-making
within the firm in a way that leads to
better decisions make sure that when a
major decision is being made that many
divergent views are heard make sure that
there isn't a leader who sort of
announces
the view that he wants to reach at the
start and then everyone else just
follows along try and avoid those
preconditions for groupthink I mean one
very basic idea that has emerged over
the past three decades in psychology is
that behavior is not so much a function
of people's personality it's a function
more of their environment and therefore
we can really alter people's behavior by
altering the environment by structuring
an environment that leads to better
decision-making so I'm hoping that the
social psychologists will work more on
that on thinking about organizational
structures that lead to better decision
you've looked at the psychological
dimensions of a problem that I might
suggest is inherently structural in your
original slide we look for instance a
credit rating now instead of looking at
the top of the tree let's look down the
tree credit rating failed for the same
reason I would contend the system is now
paralyzed which is conflict of interest
and if we see that as a structural issue
we can look at your authority figure
models and the like and deduce some
solutions which we have yet to implement
specifically for instance underlying the
fiduciary assumption of public equity
markets we could separate the role of
CEO and board chair as a matter of law
the dick Grasso excess spoke to it and
yet to this day nobody is attacked the
structural issue of conflict of interest
which might restore trust to the market
do you see a psychological explanation
or a political explanation to the
failure to solve that problem yes so
you're rightly bringing our attention to
the conflicts of interests at the
ratings agencies and there is no doubt
there's no doubt that that is a big
problem and I would like to see a change
there and it probably took or will take
a crisis like the one we've just been
through to really force a change
I just wanted to suggest that there's
other things going on because to even
bring those mortgage-backed securities
CDOs to the ratings agencies to rate
someone had to make those loans in the
first place the local loan originators
had to make the loans the borrowers had
to
they had to get sold to investment banks
were willing to package them there were
so many other components of this and I'm
just trying to suggest that was
psychological factors that agrees to
that process but I'm glad you brought up
what you did because there's clearly
major problems with the ratings agencies
and we need to address those as well
thank you for calling on me I'm Bronwyn
Bateman and I went to UC Berkeley at a
time when Yale did not admit women and I
also chaired the conflict of interest
committee for the entire UCLA campus but
my comment is really a psychological one
and it has to do with predatory loaning
and the people at high levels who were
very well-educated understood
economics incentivized people at the
bottom of the pyramid to sell loans and
I
I represent Nicaragua in the state of
Colorado and there are so many Hispanics
who take out these loans not very
well-educated it's done in Spanish but
the people at the bottom of the pyramid
are incentivized so the people at the
top incentivize the people at the bottom
and it was very predatory you know when
you're educated and you do something
stupid you say gosh I made a mistake but
the people at the bottom were just taken
advantage of and then those loans were
packaged and all kinds of problems
ensued but the fundamental problem was
incentivizing people at the bottom of
the pyramid yeah so you it sounds like
you're you're quite convinced about what
we call the bad incentives view at the
start and I think that's definitely many
people have that view and I think it is
a reasonable one again just to put
side-by-side the more benign narrative a
lot of people think that actually this
the innovation of subprime lending was
actually a very good innovation at a
smart innovation that allowed people at
the sort of lower socioeconomic end to
borrow and own their own
home the idea was that you could give
these people alone and then the value of
their house would go up and then they
could refinance and it would all kind of
work out it was actually viewed as a
clever piece of financial innovation and
to some extent it is a clever piece of
financial innovation I just think we
went too far with it so there was a more
benign narrative I don't want to suggest
that everything here is rotten at the
core but I certainly your point is
well-taken and I agree with the
direction you're going
well well because your analysis suggests
that these problems that derive from our
basic psychology it looks like we're
afraid to always repeat these cycles a
kind of a feedback loop into a mass
hysteria that will bite us possibly more
quickly as the speed of transactions
increases is there a way to just put a
brake on the excess rather than try to
in fact think our way out of it just to
prevent these cycles from spinning so
quickly so preventive measures well
going back to the issue of regulation I
do think that we're going to see a and
not quite a lot of regulation in force
and some of that I think will be very
sensible I just wanted to come back to
one thing you said which is that you
know because these are psychological
factors we're sort of fated to always
repeat these mistakes I did want to
mention again that this very interesting
trend in psychology in the past 30 years
beginning with the work of Michele at
Columbia in the late 60s which is that
we always thought that people's behavior
was based on their personality if they
had a particular kind of personality
they were always going to act a
particular way but what we've really
learnt is that the environment matters a
huge amount you can take the same person
and put them in very different
environments and they'll act in
completely different ways and that's why
I feel more hopeful that if I can get
the social psychologists to think harder
about organizational behavior ways of
getting better decisions out of
organizations and I think I think there
is hope I'd like to see more of that
kind of work one problem is that you
really become famous in psychology by
finding a bias by finding an error a
cognitive error that people make that
work that's what makes you famous in
psychology you don't really become
famous by figuring out how to correct
that error so again you become famous
for you become famous for bias C for
bias C's finding a bias not for D
biasing and I think there should be much
more emphasis in that work on D biasing
maybe just take a couple more questions
and then let you get on with your J so
yes please I have a question about the
role in in all this of by the of these
insurance policies called credit default
swaps that you forget that piece of
jargon there insurance policy so many so
many people who invest it at the
investment and down down at the bottom
of your who bought these bonds and
securities also were told by the
financial advisors whatever by a hedge
hedge what you're doing by buying some
insurance and the people doing it knew
that this was not regulated that the
people selling whether it was a guy from
Bear Stearns or a guy from Lehman
Brothers or AIG selling you this swap
did not have did not have mandated
reserves to back up the insurance you
knew nothing there was a complete
asymmetry of information and and it
seems to me in this situation I don't
know if you agree that the the in this
situation the asymmetry encouraged the
people to buy the bond and because and
by this and by the insurance by the swap
to back it up with more confidence
because they expected that the guy from
Bear Stearns if he's willing to sell me
this insurance on this bond he's got a
lot more information that I do I don't
know any you know he's willing that he
must be confident that this bond is good
otherwise he wouldn't sell me the
insurance policy and I wonder if you
think that kind of sort of backup
confidence in all of these financial
instruments that were sold in such huge
numbers was a factor because this is a
situation where asymmetry encourage use
to go ahead not not to hang back not to
not make the trade it encourages you to
make the trade you
I'm saying yeah there's an interesting
idea asymmetry actually leading to more
trade rather than less I mean I think
the crucial error there is people not
thinking about whether the credit
default swap contract could actually be
fulfilled in event of adverse
circumstances and that I I again pull
back to the bad model problem people
really didn't have models that forecast
the kind of bad scenarios we've been
through and I honestly think it it was
it was it was genuinely hard at the time
to forecast this scenario and a lot of
small people failed to do so your
question or the questions seem to follow
the fault line you started with between
rationalism and emotional
decision-making everyone wanting to
ascribe either the ability to correct
things because they're systemic and we
can Pinker with them or perhaps no it's
just innate I I don't know do you
recommend that your students read the
extraordinary popular delusions and the
madness of crowds which I think I was
recommended 40 years ago there is a
periodicity these things happen over and
over and over and over again
so do you think that that is a lack of
information and if you merely tell the
people who are acting emotionally that
they're misinterpreting the odds that
they won't become a different kind of
decision-maker and socially do you think
that it's possible to become more
rational collectively so the issues that
are correcting some of these biases so
what I would say is a number of
questioners have sort of said I think to
some extent rightly that a lot of these
psychological factors really are deep in
the human psyche and so yes it's not
possible just sort of snap our fingers
and suddenly start to think rationally
we have all these heuristics and so on
that may have been evolutionarily very
useful they're just not very useful
today in today's market there is
research on whether people can correct
their biases on whether they can learn
their way out and definitely looking at
evidence can help understanding your
error can help you to learn your way out
of biases but it's not completely
successful and that's why I think again
some organizing
creating organizations which lead to the
best possible decision making by having
many different points of view so that
each individual error can cancel out I
think is maybe the most useful direction
and I hope that you know if you come
back in five years we'll have more
research to tell you about that thank
you
you